contraste luminosité colorimétrie le
mail d'un pro et franchement
[Musique]
m
il est quelque chose comme cinq heures
et demie j'ai un vol à 9h direction las
vegas 6 heures de vol un peu rock'n'roll
mais c'est pas grave ça va être plutôt
cool direction le cis qui commence
demain dans ce genre mais qui a quand je
profite de mon voyage pour tester la
caméra photo vidéo d'une et de 20 pour
doit ou non non je vais le faire comme
ça j'en profite à partir net non j'ai
tout filmé uniquement avec le médecin
pro excusez moi je prend doucement je
pas réveillé tout le monde dans l'hôtel
et se filmer uniquement avec le médecin
pro faire des photos plein de choses
avec eux en sera un débrief à la fin ça
c'est mes de l'impro on va voir si la
caméra est ok on va parler suffisamment
stabilisée voir les photos on va
regarder plein de trucs ça va être super
cool la bombe est grand temps j'ai mon
vol qui décolle dans deux heures une
heure je sais pas on est sûr la caméra
avant donc là on se teste la caméra
avant va voir si c'est ok tu vois une
espèce de grand chocolat c'est marrant
parce que si c'est pas du chocolat en
poudre c'est un truc liquide qui rajoute
ya meilleur athlète board
[Musique]
bon là on sautait sur les caméra arrière
départ pour las vegas
si une petite heure finir ce test
directement la senior cp au final on
verra si c'est cool les photos sont bien
là kto dire je vous ferai un débrief
complet sur place
[Musique]
las vegas la ville
vous avez des machinations partout
machine ici directement dans l'aéroport
[Musique]
où elle comme las vegas bien dans l'airé
à las vegas je vais aller faire quelques
courses parce que forcément j'ai besoin
de manger un peu le matin c'est bruyant
aussi j'ai besoin de me rappelle matin
un petit déjeuner et je suis allé dans
un magasin je ne connaissais absolument
rien qu'il faut sont pas découverte des
produits américains
singer presspass de deux juges humex
fraise banane de muffins seule espèce de
truc avec du chocolat dans pomme cake
kitkat et craintif voilà ça c'est bien
beau dommage j'aurais fait un petit tour
la chambre pour montrer un peu ce qu'il
en est là pour l'instant on va se
concentrer on va parler de la photo et
de la vidéo sur le web mais devint pro
sent le mec 20 pro vous avez un
triplement du photo l'arrière 40
mégapixels un capteur grand temps qui
ouvre à f 1.8 un deuxième c'est le vin
mégapixels c'est un ultra grand angle
qui ouvre à f 2.2 il vous avez un tel
objectif 8 mégapixels avec un zoom x 3
qui ouvre à f 2.4 et ici et là vente
d'une petite caméra de 24 mégapixels ça
c'est pour la partie hardware maintenant
de concentrer sur la partie software la
partie logicielle du match d'impro pour
la photo la vidéo est vraiment très
sympa et très bien maîtrisée là vous
êtes en photo je dirai tout ce qui a de
plus normal là vous êtes en mode normal
jusqu'en x 3 vous êtes sur le zoom
analogique
ensuite vous passez en zoom numérique et
vous monter jusqu'à x 10 bon après et
franchement c'est pas terrible terrible
mais en tout cas ça le mérite d'exister
autre point qui est très sympa lorsque
vous allez descendre hop je me mets à 1
vous allez descendre vous arriver
ensuite hop vous changer d'objectif vous
passez sur l' ultra grand-angle alors
ultra grand-angle et pas mal par contre
on en effet fiche arrive forcément ça va
déformer
mais c'est assez pratique c'est pas mal
lorsque vous voulez vraiment faire des
photos groupe photographie quelque chose
vous avez besoin de beaucoup plus
d'ouverture de largeur ça vous permettra
de la voir alors là je vous le montre en
faisant glisser comme ça sur le côté
vous avez qu à cliquer également dessus
ça marche très bien
on se remet comme ça vous cliquez là
vous êtes fois un x 3 si vous passez x 5
et or si vous allez sur le grand-angle
voyez
fois 0,6 donc ça c'est assez simple bon
vous avez la possibilité de venir
modifier les couleurs avoir des couleurs
plus vivre avoir des couleurs plus
douces bon je conseille de rester en
mode standard et si vous avez quelques
paramètres alors en termes de résolution
vous pouvez choisir 40 mégapixels 10
mégapixels cette méga pixels 6
mégapixels
ça c'est à vous de choisir et lorsque
vous avez sur le mode pro vous allez
pouvoir choisir le format raw ensuite on
va continuer vous allez allez sur le
mode portrait vous allez pouvoir
rajouter quelques éléments des coeurs
des tourbillons france est très sweety
vous allez pouvoir changer aussi
l'éclairage faire un éclairage de seine
ça c'est aussi assez marrant le mode
chez nocturne est vraiment très
intéressant par contre c'est hyper
important il faut vous mettre sur un
pied si vous n'êtes pas posé souhaite
pas bien stabilisée tout de suite c'est
hyper compliqué le mode ouverture on va
pouvoir régler ensuite votre ouverture
ici bon ça c'est un grand classique ça
marche aussi super bien la vidéo qui est
pas mal mais peut faire mieux vous allez
pouvoir filmer jusqu en 4k uhd vous avez
également le mode pro bon le mode pro
comme son nom l'indiqué c'est vraiment
pour venir chercher à gratter dans les
paramètres faut quand même être
certainement connaisseur pour pouvoir en
tirer le meilleur parti et après vous
avez d'autres possibilités ralenti
panoramique monochrome
vous avez le filtre à air pour ça c'est
assez marrant voyez en face je fais
parler
le petit panda 1 voilà ça c'est rigolo
travailler pas mal de petites options
lightpainting time lapse filtre panorama
3d filigrane document car on voit qu'en
terme de côté software c'est vraiment
hyper hyper hyper hyper complet il y
avoit qui est très sympa en utilisant le
très grand angle ça vous fait également
un mode macro alors je l'essayé j'étais
à l'agglo pris des photos sur un burger
j'ai fait avec ce que j'avais et c'est
très intéressant
vous pouvez prendre photos jusqu'à 2 5
cm et franchement le résultat est assez
bluffant
je fais pas mal de photos tout à l'heure
lorsque je les mange un bout en arrivant
directement vegas je vous montre un
petit peu le rendu alors hop au début ça
c'est l'objectif principal photo
complètement normal là j'arrive sur le
zoom analogie zoom numérique on part
tout en détail on récupère en bruit et
là on est sûr l'objectif très grand
temps de voiliers par un tour romane
normal ça change vraiment je sais
exactement la même distance vous le
voyez il ya un côté un peu fisheye mais
franchement ça fait vraiment le job là
je vous ai fait une photo qui prise
directement avec le mode macro alors
mise à part le fait que ce soit un petit
peu dégueulasse sans ma boîte chez mcdo
comme ça ça fait franchement bien la
faire c'est assez bluffant
regardez vous avez la même chose sur mon
père y sommes
bien que ça donne faim mais franchement
au-delà du côté burger un peu dégueu
vous avez quand même un vrai détail qui
repris ici au niveau de l'image et pour
sas mediapro et excellent mode macro la
voyez j'ai fait une fois de plus la même
chose
photo normale photo très grand-angle
c'est franchement bluffant
et en plus ce qui est vraiment très
intéressant alors davantage sur le mode
normal c'est qu'on voit que les couleurs
sont vraiment bien restituer les
contrastes sont ok les lumières sont
naturels pour moi est un vrai beau
boulot est un vrai beau traitement
d'image alors le mot grand-angle et moi
parfait au niveau des couleurs mais
franchement ça fait aussi le job et la
voyez en mode macro sur l'afrique de
mcdo ça marche très bien
contraste luminosité colorimétrie le may
20 pro et franchement excellent pour
faire des photos
je vous montre quelques photos que j'ai
fait aujourd'hui et vous allez voir
franchement résultat est assez bluffant
[Musique]
c'est ma vous montrer une photo que j'ai
pris avec le mode nuit c'était ce matin
pas tout à l'heure en tout cas trouille
york
regardez le résultat est complètement
bluffant l'image est vraiment juste
magnifique
les noirs ressorte super bien les
couleurs les lumières y ait une vraie
gestion qui est magnifique un revenu qui
est juste incroyable par contre je
trouve ça vraiment super mais à la fois
c'est loin d'être parfait parce que
lorsque vous allez prendre des photos en
mode nocturne
il va falloir le tenir sans bouger
pendant 5 secondes tenir votre appareil
pour moi comme ça déjà c'est mort
pendant 5 secondes dans sa bouche du
tout et c'est franchement pas hyper
évidence couvrir d'or des images qui
sont assez imprécise et c'est assez
dommage vous avez donc besoin d'un petit
tripode comme ça pour le coup c'est à
mon avis ce qu'être mieux c'est ce que
j'ai fait ce matin vous prenez vous le
posez comme ça vous le posez vous voulez
directement et vous art des clichés
nocturne qui sont juste incroyables vous
allez options qui sont assez marrante
pour le mode portrait vous avez
différents effets alors le détourage ça
fait franchement très très bien c'est
assez marrant alors y'a plein d'options
rigolote dessus et après on choisit on
fait ce qu'on veut un petit peu ça c'est
vraiment pour le côté un petit peu fun
mais je trouve qu un vrai beau détourage
via un bon traitement logiciel là dessus
aussi franchement les mecs 20 prof un
très bon boulot pour moi sans conteste
le médecin pro est vraiment excellent en
photo dans plein de modes différents
autant il est excellente au point de vue
là autant en vidéo c'est pas là où il
est le meilleur je pense que c'est
vraiment un point améliorée de la part
du web pour faire que leurs téléphones
qui sont d'excellents photophone
deviennent aussi d'excellents vidéophone
voilà c'est tout pour cette vidéo sur le
mail 20 promettant va continuer tout
petit peu je vous en ai avec moi je vais
un événement tout à l'heure qui se passe
juste avant l'ouverture du csa vegas sa
tête elle comme lampe et comme c'est un
rendez vous entre les médias et des
entreprises des grosses entreprises
c'est un événement à peu privilégié des
petits fours un coup à boire enfin tout
est très sympa on va continuer là-dessus
et puis après
clap de fin et puis demain on commence
le cs vous allez voir vous allez ça va
envoyer du bois va vous emmener avec moi
faites comme qui est un évènement
organisé spécialement
pour les médias vous avez des exposants
d'entreprise de l'attaqué en règle
générale vous avez des médias qui sont
ou du monde entier qui viennent
y'a que les médias qui peuvent venir
l'un sur l'autre est autorisé à venir
connaître rencontré en petit comité de
pouvoir parler directement dans un lieu
qui est complètement privilégiés alors
là c'est long
je rends pas compte accorder la
superficie la salle s'est complètement
ouf
juste énormissime alors vous avez des
parce qu'ils sont
plus tard connu j'ai vu passer
[Musique]
il ya hp
honneur par là bas enfin un gâchis il ya
que des grosses grosses structures il
n'y a pas que des gros comme ya beaucoup
de grosses structures
et ça permet effectivement ma de prendre
un petit coup de l'intérêt qu'ils
rencontraient tranquillement dans des
conditions intéressantes assez
franchement plus en plus ce qui est
vraiment génial c'est qu'il ya des
chiens qui ne prépare à manger sur le
pouce donc apprendre plein de choses à
manger
c'est quoi ça si kate acoss
tacos faire d'elle franchement hyper
montage ils goûtent et ça là typiquement
voyez on a le nouveau au nord view 20
qui va être présenté qui est juste là
avec sa petite encoche là sur le côté
franchement c'est super bon
[Musique]
respect
oh
alors qu'ils tuent et matri
la môme à paris
[Musique]
23h10 seller dormir il reste encore deux
trois heures de boulot devant moi mais
bon pas plus de voix que ça soyez sage
tu oublié pas de vous abonner jeu pour
être plein de trucs de teck coule au cms
open jaws cool on en reparle dans les
jours qui viennent
prenez soin de vous ciao